c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
patrick s'est passé au futur
ouais comme toi comme tout le monde
mieux mais [ __ ] c'est génial c'est au
[ __ ] tu connais tu connais le plat
favori de de rocco siffredi la wdcs
radiata et d'ailleurs il ya une partie
de mon spectacle qui a été co écrite par
quelqu'un qui vous avez travaillé et qui
vous passe le bonjour
donc je suis content mais c'est pas mon
cul
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez que la france aille mieux
il s'agit de faire une chose sa part de
l'épaule droite
je trouve ça veut dire que nico tôt
quand on est content et bon dans sa dose
de l'épaule que ça fait de la sardine
alors ou ailleurs je fais faire de la
sardine pendant cinq ans il est en
tournée dans toute la france où il faut
aller le voir florent peyre je ne perds
jamais aucun jeu vous avez le choix
entre cheveux au vent ou 24 heures avec
jean michel maire qu'est ce que voulait
comme thème florent jean-michel alors
vous devez prendre une voix suave de
téléphone rose pour lui faire deviner
les mots à trèbes être moins rapidement
je vais faire comme l'afrique ou
[Musique]